so I think it's time to get started
please feel very welcome to this
presentation called DD really matters I
am Jimmy demonism from Sweden and I will
do my best to speak English today I will
actually also speak some German and some
Swedish thus if if that's understandable
so I've been in the business of software
development for 30 years now actually I
start stopped counting I guess it's a
few more and I an idea of staying here
for a while more so how many of you are
developers in here
lots of hands architects quite many
testers project managers CIOs CTOs okay
great and some of you are hybrids I
guess it's always hard to answer those
questions
am i developer or an architect I guess
lots of you are both so now I know how
who I'm going to found here and I can be
really nasty to the CTOs and CIO so
let's try that actually I think I have
most to say about developers as a matter
of fact so earlier I used to be an agile
layest
dd-dear and I've been that for a long
time I think I'm more like that nowadays
actually it's just growing on me after
all those years so I will continue on
that path for more years I think because
I love to learn new stuff ok with that
out of the with that down let's start
with the presentation so the idea of
this presentation is is to try to come
up with a couple of proposals that I've
collected during my career for how to
really elevate the business of your
clients for us developers helping your
clients to really become successful I'm
sure you have lots of ideas in this area
as well so let's talk about that
afterwards with a beer
it's a beer or bear I always have a
trouble
with that let's have one of those the
one we drink okay so we'll start with a
couple of observations here and see if
you recognize any of those the first
observation is me going to a workshop
with really hardcore security people
military great security people they they
invited me to the workshop because they
wanted to hear a little bit about how
developers think about initiating a new
project so you in the DD field how do
you do they asked me and I told him a
couple of ideas of how we typically get
started I didn't I wasn't able to tell
them a lot before they were totally
shocked they were amazed of how reckless
I was they said how how can you be so
not thinking about security at the first
page for example of course you have to
start with a security assessment of the
information that is being used in the
system and I was a bit surprised
actually because well how can I start
there that's in my world a bit wrong
it's a little bit too early it's a bit
about starting with talking about how
thick solid or be and who mentioned a
house at all maybe it was a bike I I
couldn't really see it as they did I
still don't actually the second example
this is the CIO he's out in a town going
to stores for buying stuff because here
is another initiative just about to be
started and he has decided we definitely
need a workflow package
he hasn't talked to the business yet at
all so we don't know what is supposed to
be done but everybody needs that or it
could just as well be a really large
package for being agile a product for
making it possible to be agile that's in
the same area
third example this time also the same
theme something new is about to get
started I take a walk over to the
operations department - yeah just have a
cup of coffee with them and she chat a
little bit and I mentioned that well
have you heard about the product that
might start up in a couple of weeks she
gets pissed on me why on earth am I the
last one to hear about this she says we
have to order servers we need to decide
protocols it's a lace and so on and so
forth and I said whoa I can't answer any
of those questions yet nothing has been
decided I have no clue what what the
direction will be here but she kind of
calms down when I promised that she will
be the first to know about everything
nothing else will start before that and
the fourth example again a very
experienced person this is a product
manager coming into a client of mine
again for helping out with an upcoming
initiative the product manager spends a
couple of months creating a very large
tree of documents
it looks quite professional I had to
admit but a bit later I have a look at
that document tree and I find it's each
document I only have headers
they are only templates something should
go in there someday when something is
decided again a bit strange I think have
you seen any of those or does it sound
out that I'm just making you from my
weird world a few nods I'm sure you can
find more on the same theme here the
message here isn't there that they are
unprofessional or evil or anything like
that not at all they are really skilled
people and this didn't work out this
wasn't the way I wanted it to happen
this was what I what I would say wrong
in different ways and I think what
happened here was that if you focus on
the speciality and you do that in vacuum
it's typically not
going to turn out well it's very much
about doing activities at high speed
very professionally but you're not
getting anywhere going anywhere so doing
activities instead of creating outcome
or doing busyness instead of business so
so I think we have a mindset problem
here and a gap so the question is how
can we create an environment and a
discussion climate for really working
together to really collaborate because
working together with all those skill
people I really want to do that because
in the in that gap between us all there
is something there was a lot of
potential a lot of interesting stuff
going on so I'd like to achieve
something else done then I painted here
before if you feel like I'm creating a
depressing feeling here now I can assure
you that the presentation will have a
Hollywood ending so it will all end well
so that was problems and developers hate
problems we want to focus on solutions
isn't that right so let's move over to
the proposals I have five of those the
first question is what to start with and
I think this is actually the absolutely
most important proposal this movie have
you seen it any one one yeah so which
one is it
Holy Grail I think someone said yeah
holy grail by Monty Python quite an old
movie still can't look at it without a
little smile on my face it's something
about Monty Python so this story is from
an interview with the young Cleese many
years ago when he told about how this
movie was created and the part of the
interview he tells is the passaggio out
certain scene that didn't work out they
shot it once they shot it twice a third
time it wasn't really funny
it was it kind of let the mood drop a
few levels so they took a break
went to table set around the table all
of them one of the team came up with a
new ID and they thought this new ID
might work let's try it out and so they
shot that new ID and it was really fun
they really this was a good time to end
the day that they said so they went home
and and took off a couple of days later
or weeks later they are looking at the
finished movie before it's going to
production and is of course it's very
fun all the parts and they they are
having a really good time but then they
come to this scene this troublesome
scene and it's still not good it still
doesn't feel right to them
so John realized this is actually not
the version we wanted so they asked the
editor what happened here and that it or
said yeah you are totally right and we
couldn't use use the version you wanted
because it was spoiled oh that's that's
bad so they asked the editor if they can
have a look at the scene anyway even if
it spoiled and he shows it to them and
they find it to be hilarious they cry
out of joy and then they ask him what
was wrong here and he's a bit tense now
he's quite irritated with them because
the spoiled scene obviously it lacks a
couple of pixels here a few seconds
probably someone had a knee in front of
the camera spoiled and yeah you can
guess what which scene made it into the
finished movie of course because it's
quite important for a comedy to be funny
so probably again this editor he was
really professional they wanted to take
care of his reputation he knew that the
whole world of editors would laugh at
that scene looking at it in slow motion
what a what a crappy editor doesn't
really matter that's not the thing about
a comedy movie for it to be technically
perfect so the answer to the question
what to start with actually have another
variant of telling the same thing here
shall I pick the boat the airplane or
the car it's impossible to answer that
question without knowing what what's the
purpose of the question so is it going
to the neighbor for a glass of wine
probably I shouldn't have any of those
or is it going to Mars won't fit either
so what to start with I think is to
start with purpose that's something we
need to begin with
so we are starting slowly now to
bridging this gap we have something that
might work out for us because we are now
both the the operations guys for example
they know the purpose of this company
now so good we are starting to have a
little bit better possibility of a
conversation now than we had before
but this bridge well we need to come
continue working on it
a long time ago when I was young I had
to make an important decision in my life
in Sweden it was mandatory to do
military services so I had to choose
between doing military services or go to
jail
and I was thinking about that for a long
time and then I decided to do it and it
was worse than I had actually expected
it to be all of a sudden I was away from
my really nice development work and I
had people screaming at me all the time
spitting in my face it was just horrible
anyway five years ago I started reading
up on military theory and it was like a
shock to me to find out that 150 years
ago they knew how to do micro services
right isn't that amazing and one of the
key things for doing it for having
warefare warfare in a dynamic setting
where everything could happen kind of
like in a business in the cup of a
company one of the key thing or the
first thing is to align on purpose
without aligning on purpose for all
those micro services or war teams you
can't have autonomy everything will be
as to wacko in the moment something
changes and in war everything changes
all the time so when they come to a
situation I we are supposed to take this
house there is no house then purpose
will help them to do the right thing
instead
so I have actually forgiven my old
officers all they wanted was to train me
to become a really good micro-service
isn't that nice
thought so if you find this maybe some
of you think well this is obvious but
when you go back to home to your company
I would I would guess that quite a lot
of your colleagues having thought a lot
about this and even worse I quite often
find it that the top management in
companies all around have a thought a
lot about it either so maybe you can get
your colleague on track and they want to
well this sounds nice
but what is our purpose and that might
not be so easy to find other people back
home at the office might say purpose is
just crap everything that counts is
making money
I hear that quite often actually that
mumbo-jumbo of fluffy purpose who cares
I don't think going strongly for a
purpose has anything to do with not
making money actually on the contrary
when people in the company really
believes in the purpose they jump out of
bed because today I'm once one more day
in my help here for curing cancer
that's actually a quite a better way of
motivating people than just giving them
some wage I would say so on top of the
wage this is much stronger much better
all of a sudden companies with a strong
purpose they make more money I would say
it's not skipping that part
so with purpose decided something really
important let's take the next one
so we are going to continue building on
this bridge now I'm adding some pillars
here for ya adding stuff to it to make
it stronger so the context
this was also totally forgotten I think
in those four observations at the start
we are working in a certain context we
are in a certain setting all the time
for people who are doing domain driven
design how many of you are into the
domain driven design quite quite many 15
years ago when I asked that question I
never found a singular arm so except
once I found one arm and then it what
that was Eric so didn't mean that much
it has changed a lot anyway so if you
are into the domain driven design this
is always a very simple question what's
the context of course the business is
the context or the domain what else
that's so obvious that wasn't something
that was touched on on those four
initial stories at all so domain driven
design could just as well have been
named I think business driven design
because that's what it is we should let
the business drive our design we will
come back to domain driven design over a
couple of times over the presentation so
this is actually me but it's not a beer
in my hand this is actually sound
blocker so when you're going out on an
adventure you are planning it is going
to be super fun there is always someone
saying don't forget the sound blocker
and that's absolutely necessary but just
focusing on that won't take you very far
it's more like yeah yeah of course we
should do that it's necessary but it's
not sufficient and this is very much
what I find when it comes to business
development in these different companies
as well
they are thinking way more about the
defensive aspects of business
development than the offensive it's like
playing soccer in this way all all the
whole team in the goal and well yeah
that's probably the correct action in
certain point in time but it's rarely a
good way of winning in the game so I'm
not either we're saying that you should
only go for attack of course not you
need to have a balance between the two
of them but I once again I think quite
often that the business development it
has a tendency of being focused on the
defensive side such as we're not going
to do anything until we have fulfilled
all the compliance requirements have you
heard that so in three years we can
start thinking about you're taking new
markets and things like that the
offensive on the other hand is growing
markets during into new markets as
examples the first one is much more into
just cutting and the second one is about
increasing revenue maybe that's why I
think the second one is much more fun
that's what I am automatically going for
it's not unheard of companies that are
doing cost-cutting they are actually
causing damage to their revenue have you
seen that that happens quite often you
but it's kind of put under the carpet a
little bit it's not without danger
another thing about this what to focus
on here is that you can't possibly make
the cost lower than zero that would be
hard but the year to increase the
revenue that is limitless and if you can
increase the revenue a lot you don't
have to think too a lot about the cost
at all I would say so to me it makes a
lot of sense to focus on increasing
revenue definitely so well maybe the
first one is a little bit about being
driven by fear and the second one is
about being driven by inspiration or
improve of things like that the next
take on the is organizational stuff you
can if you really want outcome instead
of just activities you can also organize
for that of course in this first
organization here I'm trying to show
quite classic organic organization of
specialized departments collaborating
for creating an outcome so maybe it's
the marketing department at first they
do stuff think about what shall be done
then they toss that result over to the
next department which might be the
construction department they do stuff
toss it over to the developers toss it
to the testers and finally the client
will receive it it yeah it we have been
doing it a lot like that in the past all
those arrows here they mean friction and
delays and well every department thinks
the other department is like crazy and
dislike each other and it just comes
from this organization it's only natural
or it happens for the time a variation
here might be to organize like this
instead more like a product focused
organization I think this is commonly
named as so now instead of having
specializations in different departments
we create a new department picking
people from different specializations
have put them together all the friction
and delays are gone in this organization
everybody are very close to the client
in the prior in the first version the
marketing team was very far away from
feedback from the client so typically
this works out much better I would say
I'm sure there are situations when it's
wrong but more more or less most often I
find that to be the best one and it
works out until
maybe the CFO sees that you are actually
doing similar stuff for two places are
you crazy he would say or she would say
are you having HR at two places we can't
have it like that that's costly let's go
for having specialized HR and then it
continues and then we are all back to
the first variant again strangely enough
I've been trying it out a couple of
times on that kind of people who who
think a lot about cost and duplication
and not too much about efficiency and
revenue and ask them how would you deal
with the crisis situation strangely
enough they would definitely go for the
second one immediately
they that's how we do the we everybody
we need for solve the problem we put
them in a room lock the door and tell
them they can come out out when they are
done that's the second one so they kind
of have it in them I'm not sure why they
try to fight it if it even when it
actually works out really well I would
say that developers have a tendency of
disliking the ID of the second one at
first at least it could be like the
developer saying me hanging out with the
sales guy then that's the worst I've
ever heard of but ironically I think
developers hanging out with sales guys
and other specializations they are
actually becoming better developers it's
not just about creating better outcome
it's good for them as well and of course
you can can go over to your other
colleagues in the other team from time
to time but your first priority is is
the outcome from your team that's just
the ID another gap
between managers and developers it's
quite commonly a situation of not
understanding each other too well but I
have a super simple model that I'm using
quite often here that I think works
quite well it's like all other models
that they are all wrong but some are
useful and I think this is useful but
you will be able to tear it down in a
few seconds I'm sure the idea is like
this the the managers typically think
more about money than the developers
developers typically think more about
the code than than managers but you
could actually kind of connect those two
because code is kind of like money and
for example we are creating code for
creating value value is measured in
money or I think it's more costly to
maintain a very large code base compared
to a smaller one would you agree to
million lines of code is typically more
costly than 10,000 so you could tell the
manager that well one single line of
code would cost you like one pound a
year in maintenance and again I know all
of you are now thinking I'm going to
write very long lines and well you can
tear it down but it kind of helps you if
you want it to because all of a sudden
the manager would now start thinking
here oh why didn't they tell me before
now I understand why the developers are
whining all the time about crappy code
and not having time to make it right and
things like that oh maybe we shouldn't
add that stuff on speculation because
that in 10 times in 10 years that will
cost us millions to maintain and I'm not
sure about it and all of a sudden they
start thinking in the right direction
actually they the managers they will be
so fond of you because now they
understand that all you are thinking
about is their money and they start to
cry
because they love you now strangely
maybe this is not so useful for your us
developers but think about it would you
like to be able to discuss with the
manager then you can use it I realize
this is not a developer centric model
it's a collaboration centric model so
why why is this model helping us I think
it kind of makes us go in the right
direction not just as developers but the
whole the whole company because I think
sighs when it comes to codebase is
tremendously important so trying to make
it they could be small it's a good thing
because when the size of a code base
grows then you will automatically
increase the cost as well you will see
more bugs the delays will be harder and
bigger and what is the reaction now we
have a codebase growing rapidly what
will someone say now maybe the project
manager we have to rewrite that with the
architecture not the project manager for
Christ's sake no no no no no I think
they praise anyone might say we are too
few here we need to add people and now
the scary stuff starts adding people
will most probably lead to exactly we
get more code and this is a very vicious
circle going rapidly down and we are out
of control here I would say there was a
book written 40 years ago called the
mythical man-month
and there's a formula in the book that
quite interesting actually if you have
if you are on a delayed project with
that formula you can calculate how much
more delayed you will be if you add one
person so if you if you don't want to
ever finish just add lots of people and
that will do the job for you
this codebase wasn't written by two
developers or three it wasn't 2000 Eider
but quite many and I think this picture
becomes really scary when you realize
it's actually not a dependency diagram
for classes
it's a dependency diagram for assemblies
isn't that what keeps you awake at night
[Music]
yeah really scary stuff it's not around
any longer but that's typically not
happening when you are only two
developers in the team you don't have
time to write a lot of code like that
how could you possibly do that you have
to find out there are solutions more
smaller solutions for getting the job
done so start with purpose remember to
think about the context being the
business and that the it's all about
creating outcome that was the two first
proposals the third one how to work so
again we are doing more on the bridge
here now this is a preparation for the
next step that will take is very far
with creating a really strong bridge
it's still very weak I might be able to
walk over it every now and then but I'm
not going to do it often I'm a little
bit heavy also nowadays so that's part
of the problem I guess but no we need
more here so the third idea is to focus
on language again something that is very
very strongly proposed in the
domain-driven design book the ubiquitous
language so some of you might have said
from time to time as a developer I'd
love to speak to the domain experts
because that's what the book telltale
talks a lot about but the domain expert
doesn't have time for me have you ever
had that feeling they don't have time
for me I think it could be two reasons
maybe a few more but the two most
typical I would say is either the domain
expert don't care about what you're
doing and then there is typically only
one solution to that and that's to live
you can't possibly succeed with the
domain expert you don't care it's
obviously not important so leave that
product as soon as possible the second
reason is that they might find you a
little bit boring I know this is offense
to be offending you here but maybe you
have seen it you go into the domain
experts office and you kind of take a
step into his room and then you start
talking about repositories and
side-effect free functions and yada yada
it takes one word of those and then the
domain expert gets a blank face like
this and then he remember a very
important meeting very quickly that's
not good so now the story I'm from my
life I was going to Austria Keats bill
for skiing with my my wife and my
youngest son we were standing in a ski
ski lift queue waiting for our turn all
of a sudden there is a very small boy
skiing over to us standing next to my
wife so we have lined up like this it
was a four-seater or a lift and we are
three and now he stands next to to my
wife and we that's a little bit strange
my wife thinks because she hears the ski
teacher
screaming something like afternoon
afternoon glide in the grappa which kind
of means come over to the group stay in
the group and my wife thinks this is a
not too nice maybe they think we would
kidnap him or something so she starts
doing like this and kicks him and and he
is screaming back to his ski teacher
that I don't actually know what because
I don't know German
but something probably said leave me
alone and then he turns over to us and
says you're below him here and that
Swedish meaning I want to go with you
so what obviously had happened here was
that he heard us speak in the queue area
he heard
Swedish and he wanted really wanted to
speak to us he actually liked us just
because we shared that language and in
the in the ski lift going up to the top
he talked actually I couldn't say
anything because he talked all the time
in Swedish and he had a really good time
and yeah we didn't kidnap him but we
could we could easily kidnap that boy he
wouldn't even have noticed actually so
he it turned out he lived in Sweden
every summer and yeah that's nice but I
thought that was actually it's almost
too powerful to share a language so
taking that story back to the problem of
the domain experts when we realize that
they don't find it too interesting to
talk about the developer stuff we we can
actually dude kind of the opposite and
use this trouble to become a superpower
of us we start trying to speak their
language as much as we possibly can
something very dramatic will change now
they they will lock the door they won't
let you go because you are such a nice
guy to talk to you they will love you
and when you go to the pub in the
evening you will notice the domain
expert is following you that's a little
bit scary at first but they wouldn't
hang out with you you are interesting
and you are starting to together not
just listening to them and collecting
the ubiquitous language it's very much
about creating the ubiquitous language
together because they are not having the
perfect crisp language that the compiler
will understand they are saying the same
word for
different things and and different words
for the same thing and they need your
your skill of detecting those problems
it gives the other way around as well
when you talk about their business
problem in their language and how you
have solved it in code they will detect
a bug like that that's not how it works
they would say to you they are
incredible at doing that because now you
have really quality communication going
on and that's really something to to
long for when I say a domain expert I
don't mean someone who can do the job
that that's not the thing the the domain
expert it's not either about knowing the
old system typically those kinds of
people are named the domain expert
I think it'll mean next part is
something else domain expert of course
he or she can do the job but they are
kind of like the best in the world in
their field and they can not only do the
job they can actually on a meta level
build a machine to do the job they are
thinking in that way and now you realize
that there are not that many domain
experts around and that actually only
makes it even more important to take
care of them because you really want to
hang out with them as much as possible
and all of a sudden your work will be
much more fun the results will be much
more better and every now and then there
is a breakthrough that is just amazing
to experience how everything just
becomes better so
fortunately not red wine okay so we are
using the best building material in the
world software software is magic
because when we have built something
created something within software we can
just check if it's doing what we want it
to if it's not we just press control set
and we are back back to the previous
stage or back space for taking it out
and it's super soft to make changes to
it so this building material it would
make the carpenter go nuts if he had
something similar it's way way better
strangely enough this is not how it's
working in practice I would say because
this curve here shows what is kind of
like law of nature to most people in the
world regarding software when they would
like to make a change to a piece of
software that cost the cost of that
change increase over time and it's
increasing rapidly very rapidly it's
quite fast that you need that rewrite
that was mentioned here what I can't do
any changes any longer it cost a million
to make anything so there is no escape
maybe in a couple of situations that's
kind of strange that software is
becoming like that when it's is such a
beautiful material to use and this is
not what we want of course we prefer
this curve instead it's it is a little
bit more expensive to make a change
later on in the lifecycle of a system
but the the increase in cost is not
going banana it's kind of flat after a
while so what are you using for getting
that second curve what is your favorite
tool how do you achieve it this is one
of those questions you can
say anything and I will say it's correct
because there are so many things DDD
someone said yes that's correct
tdd the best developers domain experts
all of those things you can't just pick
one you have to pick a lot of things and
it's hard work every day but it's
possible to achieve and this is actually
super important for the company you're
working for because if you have that
second kerb all of a sudden the business
people have the possibility of making
several tries or several attempts with
their IDs with the first curve they had
one ID typically the first ID doesn't
work out as you want to and the second
ID is impossible because it became too
expensive on the other hand with the
second curve that's a really really
beneficial situation to be in for a
company that needs to be do be doing
business development all the time so
this is not just us being wanna create
good stuff for our own sake this is
actually helping the company a lot very
valuable on the same page here of
focusing on language there was a paper
written 25 years ago called language
oriented programming and the idea is
that not you just use the
general-purpose language for solving all
problems some for some parts in a system
it might be very beneficial to create a
new language together with the business
expert that is actually his or her
language this is how I would express
myself and from that point in time they
can actually take care of that part of
the application on their own or at least
that quality discussion I talked about
before when we talk to each other in a
very good way now we are actually
programming together it's not forbidden
for a business person to program with
you I think that's super cool when that
happens and when that's possible I'm
very very beneficial
but we are quite fast of talking with
the domain expert and then say please
leave I have to open visual studio now I
think that's the common and I think
that's wrong actually I think we can do
a lot here I've been doing this for
quite many years now and it's
unfortunately bit more tricky than you
you might first think but I still
believe this is the next big thing so in
10 years I will come back here and tell
you it was I was right
is that ok have you tried it no that's
actually lovely ok some some has yeah
but the rest of you here we have
something really fun to dig into this is
both fun as a technical challenge as it
is for a way of getting closer to your
domain experts it's both parts of it
it's a long different story but you can
google it and ping me if you want to
talk more about that ok we have done
three things now time for our proposal
for now we are using it what we've done
to the bridge before and we kind of make
it really strong now so after this
proposal it should work out for bridging
the gap and we should be able to
collaborate so this fourth ID proposal
is to use the circle of safety you might
have noticed it especially this is the
case in large organizations and old
organizations that when a small group is
starting a new initiative all of a
sudden the immune system of the this
corporation goes off and try to kill
that new initiative have you seen that
it happens all the time because this big
organization it's not out of evilness
either or it just happens it's kind of
like it wants everything to stay the
same please let us have status quo no
new ideas
say so if you are about try out some new
IDs you need to put up very high fences
around that most typically should
actually not do it at the company at all
do it in secret some some somewhere else
because otherwise it won't work out for
you if you have that protection around
that little team it's not just the
outside that might be the problem
because all of you are sitting in here
all your ancestors very far away back in
time they were quite afraid they were
very careful people so when they heard a
little noise like some some leave making
a sound they immediately thought that
that might be a liar and they took off
and that was quite a good tactic back in
the days because life was yeah it was
more dangerous than nowadays
unfortunately that was a good tactic
back then nowadays it's typically not
because our brain is kind of still the
same it evolves quite slowly so when you
are in a team working it together in a
very good way and you don't just get
disturbance from the outside but one one
day one of your team members come come
in the morning and he doesn't say hi
then your brain tells you danger this is
not good and you think for a second is
is he going to kill me no it's probably
not but the whole day you are thinking
about this all your energy is actually
lost just because of that isn't that
really we have to think about how to
behave the next day the same colleague
behaves the same way now you're
definitely sure he will kill you and all
of a sudden there is no energy being
used for creating outcome alone
the Energy's thinking oh how this is not
good so we have to think very carefully
about this also how we are talking to
our colleagues all the time I have a
little tip here that has helped me a
couple of times a communication style so
imagine a meeting maybe 10 people and
then I tell someone stop looking at the
phone and that creates not such a nice
atmosphere in that meeting not only that
nobody is listening any longer after I
said that nobody will hear what I'm
saying because they are thinking what's
wrong with him he's it's typically nice
he's behaving like an and is
that because and and they start making
stories again all those stories they are
not very logical
they are always taken to the most
possibly extremely negative they could
possibly be so all of them have you kind
of decided I am deadly sick or something
or it must be very very bad but I could
use this is that I could have said the
same thing in four dimensions I could
say I observe I think I feel I want for
example something like I can see that
you are looking at your phone all the
time that makes me think that you might
not want to be in my project and that
makes me feel very sad because I really
want you in my project something like
that it I hope it was a little bit less
threatening than the first version I
think so and this is slower but on the
other hand
it saves hours and hours of energy loss
quite often I forget about this but you
can always go back if you have a
troublesome situation go back and try
again you can try again many times and
it's not getting a worse problem and you
might
it's something important I think in that
circle of safety is the possibility of
failing forward if you are not allowed
to fail well that's a troublesome
situation I went to a big car producer
in Sweden many years ago for discussing
a new project and I was very proud when
I got there and I told them that I
probably have the world record in
mistakes I said and I thought that was
now they will love me they hated me they
wanted to kick me out they never did any
mistakes that was the worst they had
ever heard and I thought that this is
quite strange huh how can you not do
mistakes how can you learn and have you
really tried there's a museum called the
museum of failure friend of mine is
running that and the it's ironically a
big success this thing it tours the
world I think it's been in London have
you anyone seen it anyway it's kind of
put mistakes in the highlight such as
fat free Pringle I think that's my
favorite is that a lovely ID it probably
sounded really good at first but it was
a failure but who cares now and who
remembers it it seems like failures they
come and go it's not something we are
thinking to long ago long about I think
we could take inspiration from this
actually and have a museum of failure at
each of our offices and it's not a bad
thing to have your IDs there it's
actually like oh he's that guy he's
really pushing the limits and trying
things out because as I said before it
typically is not taking one try for
creating a success but if you only have
one chance you also have this problem of
analysis paralysis because you know you
only have one try it you will think four
years before you try but if you skip
that it's totally fine to try ten times
and sooner or later you will have your
success I'm very sure ten years ago I
wrote an article and I think this was
the worst name of an idea ever had chunk
cloud computing Eric Evans actually
asked me not to use it and I should have
listened anyway what I try to describe
was that for creating a nice
organizational setting or and a nice
architecture for protecting the
different teams and the different
subsystems
you need to have borders so this is kind
of like taking the boundary context ID
and pushing it a little bit further but
to me this was yeah it's first of all
it's very much about circle of safety
and when I wrote the paper I was super
tired of trying to force everybody to
develop in the same style for example I
think that I can't live without TDD but
most people are very productive without
it so why should I force them they can
be in another team work the way they
want and create the value they they can
and and I'm not going to nag on them
because I mean another team with people
that think the same way that was one of
the reasons for this paper
it was quoted in the micro services
definition article by James Lewis and
Martin Fowler so this is actually the
reason for micro services I know that a
lot of people think that micro services
is for tiny tiny technical stuff and
technique is operations is the driver
that's wrong actually
sorry it's not about tech it's about
organization
I'm joking a little bit you can choose
whatever you want to believe of course
so finally proposal 5 now we have this
bridge and we are traveling it it's not
just us going over to the managers and
the operations and the product manager
they will come to us and we run there
all the time as much as we need and we
have this new possibility now what what
shall we use it
well I think we should use it this way I
think we should think about what are the
global bottleneck right now which is the
global bottleneck right now and we try
to solve that that's the the basic idea
here and we are not typically thinking
too much about everything we are forcing
or focusing on our core domain because
this is the place where we have our
competitive edge it feels much more
reasonable to invest money here than in
whatever is more of a generic
domain of your company for example you
might have an HR department it's
important but it's not different from
any other HR departments in the world
maybe they don't have need to have
custom software you should have that
instead where you are really creating
the value for your clients or for the
customers but first before we have a
little look at the bottleneck solving
I'd like to say a few words about people
and automation I think this actually
helps quite a lot if you think about
automation all the time that takes away
a lot of fog for finding the real
bottleneck and I think we can do a lot
more here than what we have done in the
past even in the development area have
you read the book accelerate two years
ago something like that it's actually
saying it's based on academic research
but they are saying something that is
totally amazing actually and they say
that we see a very strong correlation
between continuous delivery companies
and companies profit so if you are doing
from a continuous delivery you probably
make more money than the other companies
but that's I think that's something that
you can use for talking to your minor
ears as well so
Automation it's underutilized and we
should use it a lot I'm not saying that
people should go away I think people
should still be used for doing the
innovations and the creative stuff and
relationships people are much better at
relationships still this might change in
the future I don't know but I haven't
seen it yet so I've prefer hanging out
with another person than a computer and
socializing at least but the rest the
repetitive stuff for example which
developer is the fastest well no
developer will be the program when it
comes to repetitive tasks of course not
so finally bottleneck I'm trying to show
up on like here something is put in from
the left and probably there is some
value being added and finally there is
output coming out and yeah we're putting
in two of something and only getting one
out for some reason I think this is not
something a developer typically would do
because you are so trained in
optimization you are doing that all the
time in the code and you have learned
that it actually doesn't help to delete
all the comments in the code everywhere
it's not running faster anyway so you
wouldn't do that business people think
like this all the time for some reason
they do like this let's see vest and
adding in more stuff and is this a good
idea of course not it's only stacking up
more queue here now and that that wasn't
just bad it was actually costly or you
didn't help of course we didn't get more
out to it outcome here but we did spend
more money we actually create a mess in
that situation because stuff is piling
up and that's costly in itself and it's
creating trouble for doing anything all
of a sudden you come to walk around in
that space for example another idea
might be to well let's try to pull out
more from the other side it's the same
doesn't help at all of course we should
focus on
on solving that bottleneck instead but
why is this being yeah why those
mistakes have a couple of ideas here I
think it's quite I hear quite often well
let's let's do it anyway because it
affects so many people and I think
that's a nice thought but if you are
affecting a lot of people in your
organization but not helping out with
the bottleneck you are not doing any
difference at all you could also see
that well Google is doing it let's let's
do it and I think that's a really bad
idea should probably think about
situation not just do what the others
are doing and Google by the way it's not
the perfect company have you have you
heard that they have their own problems
so no they are doing lots of great stuff
but might have baby for us and of course
the worst problem we have very loud loud
people and they want something and they
get it but no this is not what we should
do we should try to solve the bottleneck
because then we can spend very little
money on solving that but effect is
tremendous so it's typically a situation
of spending X and getting 10x in result
and typically much much more what is
this is bit there are some traps here
for example be very sure that you are
the best friend with the CEO when you
start doing this that you have the
strong support from the top management
because when you are finding a global
bottleneck and you are taking that away
there will be a new bottleneck typically
not at the same place it gives somewhere
else those people will not be happy with
you they will hate you they will do
anything they can for
moving it back IAM and then you need the
top management's help I've tried them
without ya not a good idea that's one
thing the other thing is of course it's
very easy to get into a trap of local
optimizations we we are running at full
speed here like what I just showed you
doesn't matter you have to think about
the whole situation
so what really matters start with the
purpose the business is calm is the
context focus on language use the circle
of safety and solve the bottleneck and
then repeat with those five proposals I
think you will make a tremendous
difference to the to the company you are
working for regarding their business
results I promise the Hollywood ending
and now we have our four observations
from the beginning smiling because they
are still doing what they are really
skilled at but they are doing it
together with the rest and with us and
we are just a happy crowd really
creating a difference we are definitely
making an impact in the situation now
it's totally different from the
beginning and I think most people are
really feeling fulfilled when they feel
that they are doing a good job that's
really important for us so I have this
dream I have this dream that all the
action that you are participating in is
going on in a situation when what really
matter is the norm and not the exception
and I think it's actually up to us to
change that and make it so so it's call
for action and be our dream I will do my
best to be my dream at least that's the
ending of my presentation thank you so
much for listening and please come and
talk and about your proposals afterwards
thank you
you